I don't think people realize
how bad the devastation and the life loss is gonna be
in western North Carolina
for a while most people didn't evacuate
there was no evacuation order
they weren't ready for this and now they are stranded
I've been seeing reports of people on mountain tops
calling them mountain islands
because they can't get down cause the roads are roaded away
the only lucky thing is that people in southern Appalachia are resourceful
and they help their neighbors
and they have a lot of like skills
so prepping food preservation
I just
some of the towns me and my family visited many times are just completely gone
it is just a resting this feeling of like shock and helplessness
in the meantime it is like a sunny
beautiful day in Charleston
it just seems so bizarre for them to have gone Hurricane and not us
like it's just
this is bad
and this is
it's gonna be worse than we think